überall im land dieses zeichen
für zahllose für russland oder für copd
für den sieg autos mit aufklebern oder
fahnen und in den sozialen netzwerken
kremltreue information die anhänger
putins im zeichen des z
in moskaus innenstadt hingegen scheint
auf den ersten blick alles normal die
sonne lockt zum bummel der frühling naht
doch das ist nur der erste blick
westliche läden haben dichtgemacht kaum
noch luxusmarken lehre shops in den
sonst zu überfüllten einkaufspassagen
der stadt der westen hat gegen russland
harte sanktionen verhängt
ich denke wir werden unsere eigene
spezielle russische welt haben wir
hoffen es alles wird gut das ist
schrecklich und überhaupt wie kann man
das tun die menschen haben doch keine
schuld wir haben keine schuld aber wir
können keine sozialen netzwerke nutzen
wir können nicht in unsere lieblings
leben gehen
nun im großen und ganzen ist das
natürlich alles traurig sie haben uns
doch daran gewöhnt dass ihr freunde
hatten und jetzt sind das leider keine
freunde
in manchen supermärkten gibt es
hamsterkäufe kaum noch klopapier mehl
oder zucker hier heimlich gedrehte handy
bildern vieles was aus dem westen kam
wird ersetzt es soll kein mangel
herrschen doch die sanktionen kommen an
nicht nur bei luxus labels wir besuchen
katharina sabo china in ihrer wohnung
hier katharina ist grafikerin gerade
illustriert sie ein kinderbuch seit dem
beginn der sogenannten sonderoperation
in der ukraine wächst täglich ihre angst
am tag zuvor habe ich die reden unserer
politiker gesehen und ich verstand dass
alles sehr schlecht werden würde da
begann schon meine panik am 24 februar
und ein paar tage danach habe ich nachts
praktisch nicht geschlafen und etwa eine
woche lang konnte ich nichts essen
alles ist teurer geworden
das papier das sie für ihre zeichnungen
braucht kostet jetzt sieben bis acht mal
mehr und sie verkauft kaum noch bilder
katharina denkt darüber nach ins ausland
zu gehen mit ihrem sohn und den
haustieren eine
ausreise könnte in frage kommen
allerdings gibt es viele geflohene
russen in georgien und armenien die
keinen reisepass haben kein schengen
visum und dort sind die preise stark
gestiegen
die leute konnten nicht viel geld
mitnehmen selbst der für den export
zugelassene betrag 10.000 dollar ist
schwierig es ist hier in russland nicht
mehr möglich rubel für 10.000 dollar
einzutauschen und trubel dort im ausland
werden super monkey
katharina ist hin und hergerissen
zwischen heimatverbundenheit und angst
wirklich frei fühlt sie sich schon lange
nicht mehr in ihrem land
und putin erhöht den druck beschwört
sein land will einheit in seiner rede am
vergangenen freitag im vollbesetzten
moskauer luschniki stadion zum achten
jahrestag der krim aktion wiederholt er
seine propaganda in der ukraine werde
ein völkermord an russen verhindert
menschen gerade von diesem leiden zu
befreien von diesem genozid dies ist der
hauptsächliche der wichtigste grund das
auslösende motiv und ziel der
militäroperationen die wir im donbass
und in der ukraine begonnen haben
pathos und propaganda für den völkermord
in der ukraine gibt es keine beweise
putin will sein land auf linie und seine
anhänger stehen treu zu wir sind für ein
geeintes russland wir sind für unseren
putin für unseren präsidenten
ich weiß mit sicherheit dass meine
tochter in einem starken großartigen
land leben wird das sich gerade formiert
und ich bin sehr stolz darauf
wer nicht mitmacht lebt gefährlich fast
täglich kommen in russland neue
repressionen für kritiker
[Musik]
freie medien sind fast alle gesperrt
viele journalisten im exil oder in haft
diese woche werden facebook und
instagram gerichtlich verboten der kreml
will die kontrolle über die sozialen
netzwerke
urteil im prozess gegen alexej nawalny
putins gefährlichster gegner neun jahre
haft in straflager der vorwurf er habe
gelder seiner stiftung unterschlagen und
eine richterin beleidigt das gericht
hatte in zwölf prozesstagen keinen
einzigen beweis vorgelegt
repressionen nach innen sanktionen von
außen mehr als 300 westliche firmen
sollen sich bereits aus russland
zurückgezogen haben in dieser moskauer
pflegeeinrichtung für schwerstkranke
kinder haben sie noch gerade rechtzeitig
bei einem russischen zwischenhändler
groß eingekauft medizinisches gerät und
medikamente aus sorge vor engpässen
es gibt aber waren die nicht mehr
verfügbar sind und der lieferant sagt
nicht wann er wieder liefern kann das
gilt beispielsweise für einige arten von
masken für die beatmung unserer jungen
patienten und für einige intravenösen er
mittel
sie sind besorgt da wir nicht wissen
wann die nächste lieferung erfolgen wird
der kleine asthenie ist zehn jahre alt
und leidet an einer muskelerkrankung er
wird hier schon drei jahre lang
behandelt seine eltern sind besorgt dass
die sanktionen auch ihn treffen können
ich weiß nicht was wir machen sollen
alle geräte die auf senioren kommen aus
dem ausland und die ersatzteile auch
wir werden wohl große probleme bekommen
moskau an diesem tag im märz 2022 die
sanktionen kommen hier an vielleicht
nicht auf den ersten blick sichtbar aber
für viele schon spürbar